all right for my talk of the table we
are talking about our series my favorite
series that we're doing right now Vlad
to Dad where we helped Vlad prepare for
fatherhood as though anyone can really
prepare we do our best though and this
morning we are going to help Vlad get
ready for you might call the less
photogenic moments with your newborn you
know the ones on social media that are
the photogenic ones the adorable baby
picture is but parents will tell you
that the reality is often not a lot of
fun and very difficult well on that
subject Frida CEO and founder Chelsea
hershorn she was a lawyer for the New
York Mets sorry about that Chelsea and
the Miami Marlins and all that change
though as it does for so many people
when she became a parent her first child
uh came along and she looked around and
she was not satisfied with the products
that were available for parents well she
founded a company of her own and now
that company does a whole range of
things making everything uh for products
make it easier for newborns to take
medicine could use that uh very popular
I would say iconic and used in my
households not sucker for a baby's
stuffy nose Chelsea hirschhorn joins us
now uh welcome thank you for being here
thank you guys for having me this effect
that is called snot sucker so it's not
called the snot sucker it's called it's
called No Frida but everybody refers to
the thought suckers
we should explain that yeah no human
babies are born with lots of those
capabilities yes but they can't blow
their own nose blowing their own nose is
not one they're born with it is a
learned behavior actually most babies
cannot breathe out of their mouth for
their first few weeks of life so they're
called obligatory nasal breathers so all
the more important to keep those nasal
passages so you were a lawyer before all
this so what was the moment as a parent
where you said I'm not I don't like
what's out there I'm gonna make my own
products oh you know parenting is one of
those life experiences that I think no
one is actually prepared for
um there's no especially the first time
you're really not yeah you'll have no
idea idea what to expect there's no
manual but you're very excited very yes
excited is the reality the the there is
no manual that book What to Expect When
You're Expecting is a bit outdated you
know there's a chapter on packing your
hospital bag that tells women to pack a
sandwich for their labor coach so
um what yeah
pack a sandwich for your labor coach
don't forget I I got the list yeah so
there were several moments throughout my
first year as a parent that were these
wide on anyone tell me this moment and
so when I use the nosefrida it was you
know eye-opening to me how unprepared I
was I didn't even think about how babies
blow their own nose let alone a host of
other fairly mundane parenting tasks
that you I can guarantee you are not
thinking about cutting Nails brushing
teeth
passing gas
it's been all about which is educating
me I've got three amazing parents here
on set with me every day and but when I
I got to tell you when I first saw this
and my wife first showed me the
nosefrida I posted it on my social media
saying this has got to be a joke and
Tony his wife Katie turr uh Adriana Diaz
who works here these are my posts right
I'm like that's my wife holding it and
you can see the big smile on her face
it's going to come in handy well they
started tweeting back at me Tony wrote
like it's a lifesaver it really is this
is the best thing but people are
wondering what it is because so so this
is what it is right that is what it is
so that was the original Flagship
product you put it in your mouth and
then you put the tube right up to the
baby's nose not inside you know before
this people use that turkey baster of
syringe and it went inside the baby's
mouth it was terrible a photo went viral
of the inside of a boat pediatrician
told me that yeah that was all moldy
like a bath toy and except for ears yeah
yeah it never touches you it never nope
there's a filter inside so it never
actually goes into your mouth yeah and
yeah the Pediatric Community has been
huge Advocates on our behalf so you have
a lot of I mean there's a lot of things
here that um that Frida baby does not
just the snots oh it does say snot
sucker on it I wasn't just making that
up you have to infuse some levity for
parents it's you know this is windy that
is windy this is the only way for you to
try that one really well not the stuff
you'll be posting about stuff you'll
wonder how you lived without and you've
got this is the uh okay I can't read
what it says on the back here but this
is freedom Mom it's the Breast Care
self-care kid yeah this is really I was
just talking to some of the moms here
about how vital this is this seems to be
like a new product here because I was
telling Vlad about the baby carrier uh
and how wonderful it is better than a
stroller but there is a little issue
with the baby legs kicking at a certain
height oh yeah with a certain delicate
part of your Anatomy get an advanced
face on the because apparently a
solution that is very concerned protect
your legs what does freedom mean I think
it's such an unusual name for all of
these what does it mean Freedom means
peaceful in Swedish so it's a peaceful
nose a free from fuss and and obviously
a host of other things well beyond baby
boogers that we've now covered
particularly with the launch of Freedom
mom which was a watershed moment for us
as a brand historically there were very
few Avenues available to Brands like
ours to help women educate themselves
and prepare for that fourth trimester
postpartum recovery experience and I'm
really proud of the work myself and the
team down in Miami have done and you've
what I think is great is that you really
walk the walk you've got four kids
ranging in age from what to what my
oldest is nine then I have a
seven-year-old a four-year-old and an
eight-month-old and you brought you
brought one of your favorite Sons
[Laughter]
[Applause]
well you know
was a middle child yeah oh it's like a
birthday right away his name is Jackson
what's up Jackson Jackson what's
happening Jackson is sitting there going
that's mine
so many products of course you know
you're on the front lines every day in
Parenthood two in the morning and that's
where a lot of the inspiration behind a
lot of this Innovations we have one
quick piece of advice for Vlad as being
a supportive partner in that first try I
love that fourth trimester and well
beyond you know I think the reality is
and what I tell all parents is you can't
pour from an empty cup and so if you
think of your partner's job during those
first few months postpartum is really
recovering and taking care of herself so
that she can be the best version of
herself there's a whole host of other
child care opportunities for you to roll
up your sleeves and participate in
whether it's diaper changes cleaning
bottles so I think that you know if you
think about that time as sacred for her
not only obviously to help feed the baby
but to really recover and put best foot
forward and get real yeah there you go
you have the tools thank you so much and
you're on my speed dial I will be here